it's such an interesting tale but i have
to ask one quick question sure is the
audio going
why do you give your characters their
birth date well early on when i when
when a character
births out its name
because at some point the name comes to
me but it feels like they've declared it
to some degree like that's the notion
i'm trying to feel in my gut when
something is said
i'll
choose a random birth date out of the
sky
i'll look up all the facts all the
zodiac all the horoscope stuff i can
find about this particular day
and my belief is
the reason we read horoscopes and zodiac
and say that it's similar to ourselves
is because i think we are that zodiac
sign in the womb and then elements of
your childhood alters parts of that
zodiac sign which gives you billions of
different personalities because we all
live different backgrounds and little
tiny things start to shift even though
we have all these similarities
so i'll look up a character's birth
chart and i'll begin to decide yeah but
this character was abused or this
character went through this and so that
would alter this and that would alter
that and at some point the character
will just start to come to life and i'll
forget about it
and they'll just kind of find their
footing hopefully
and you'll be able to follow that path
so in clowning what were the two
leeds birthdays
well you know clowning is an interesting
tale because
here's how clowning came about it's a
little different my best friend
producing partner jonathan guyato
he
told me that his girlfriend was pregnant
paige is her name
and they're pregnant with their first
baby so immediately i know i want to
make my friend a little film i'm
thinking maybe like a little
documentary taking a documentary subject
putting into a narrative structure maybe
filming them while she's pregnant you
know so i have that in my head i'm
thinking about that as a movie
i go to bed and i have a dream and in
the dream you come you know when you
come to in the middle of a dream and you
already know what's been happening
i come to in the middle of this dream
and i'm driving through the desert
and i know in my head
that there's something in the back of
the van that i had nothing to do with
but everyone's after me because of this
thing
so i start to feel that tension and that
stress and as it begins to bubble i
suddenly hear a giggle to my right and i
look over and i see this female clown
and it makes me wince and fear and when
i do this i suddenly see that i'm
wearing a clown outfit and i look in the
mirror and i see paint
and i woke up from a dream and said that
mixed with my friend's real life
is a neo-noir crime film i've never seen
and in his real life he was making lip
balm called mama earth and i always have
a stick of lip balm called mama earth
that because he's got his own company
and um and i put it in the movie so he
had to give me lip balm for life for
free so it's not product placement you
don't need to buy mama earth but that's
his job right and then he gets into
yeah then he becomes a clown for hire
and before you know he's wanted for
murder and trying to prove his innocence
so and you had never had a job as a pro
you know you know some in la there's all
these you know
princess parties and these different
things where you dress as different
no no but my grandma lil
she loved clowns her whole house was
covered in clown paintings and and clown
sculptures and i always wanted to do a
movie with clowns that wasn't about
clowns
and i i like the idea that clowns are so
embedded in the horror genre today and i
wanted this movie to be a crime romance
film
and not and and just know that when they
watch it they're going to be thinking
these
this feeling there's all this horror
feeling in the picture but it's just
because of where clowns are today in our
society but the film itself is not a
scary movie sure and some of the crime
stories that have happened
with individuals who
dressed as clowns right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and so do these two characters let's say
the male clown and the female clown do
they have birthdays and what birthdays
are those
well so the male clown
in in uh milo is his name in clowning
that's closer to my friend so so so that
was more based on
jonathan galleto in his reality so there
wasn't necessarily a birthday for that
particular character now
pele i didn't pick a specific date
i just knew she was an aries
i knew that she was going to be have
this dominance about who she is and i i
knew that she would be an aries son with
a rising taurus
and so then i started to read about
those two zodiac signs early on and i
began to learn more about who she is and
then she woke up pretty fast
so there wasn't a particular birthday
for that one that was more of a broad
stroke but that's because that character
has a lot more going on than what you
realize in the beginning so
she was built differently but most
characters i'll give that that's a way
i'll give an actor some direction early
on
as i'll give them a particular
birth date and their horoscope and start
feeding them stuff every week
just to get their minds like i'd be like
here's your horoscope today and here's
how your character feels about that
based on his or her life
and so it'd be kind of some ways that we
start talking about and eventually they
take that over too and eventually i stop
doing that and
the actor will just start doing it
so it's sounds like it's pele's way or
the highway and she's never wrong
that's
that that should be the tagline
okay
how does this deep understanding of the
character help you develop the story
the character is the story
so
unless your film
is plot driven and say it's friday the
13th and perhaps in that picture
the characters being teenage
regular teenage early 20s
people
then maybe their characters aren't
necessarily driving that tale
but in general
the more you understand about your
character the more you comprehend it the
more they begin to take over the story
the beginning they begin to make choices
and if they're making choices and that's
playable actions that actors can embody
and a lot of times
there's you know a lot of films that are
put together where actors don't have
playable direction coming out of the
screenplay because plot's happening to
them
when really the character
plot should be happening because of them
so i think at the end of the day if
there's a moment you're writing
something
and you don't have a deep understanding
of the character then you're probably
writing too prematurely you probably
need to take a second
and start writing in that character's
diary because why tell the story about
you know let's say
scarface with al pacino
imagine if that character wasn't as
developed as who he became well the
movie scarface is scarface because the
character that he plays
is that psychopath that builds up into
having this huge momentum you know this
monumental moment at the end
but that's all coming from character
so if you're sitting down to write that
story and you don't know who that
character is or you're not fully
alive with that individual then they
can't make choices and then in my
opinion then maybe the story could die
or fall flat
be boring
do you think horror
dictates the k i mean you said that the
story is dictated by the character but
is that always true with horror films
well you know
in the horror realm
you have a lot of different types of
genres sub-genres in that in that in
that realm like for instance the shining
that is a story very driven on character
choice
and character needs that lead them into
that realm right but if you look at
nightmare on elm street versus friday
the 13th let's say as two comparisons of
similar genres even
nightmare on elm street you actually
have kids that have more developed their
characteristics are more developed in
nightmare on elm street to where they
actually have goals and they have things
that they're trying to
conquer in their personal lives with
their inter you know with their
relationships amongst each other where
friday 13th they're mainly just hooking
up and then getting slaughtered
with all of that said what i'm hoping to
bring into the horror genre
is a thematic idea for instance and my
film bickel that we're going to go into
making
the theme of the movie is how far would
you go for your family
and what i love about that is the theme
in horror films doesn't generally
translate
into
the realm of like from the characters
like the characters who are
innocent and getting injured throughout
the piece
they might have a thematic idea attached
to them but it doesn't usually go to the
killers usually the killers are these
mindless people just attacking
and this film bickel what i'm excited
about is
the thematic idea of how far would you
go for your family even translates over
into their world where the two killers
in the film they are family and they're
trying to protect each other
so hopefully we go into this texas
chainsaw massacre kind of genre and kind
of turn it on
on its head a little bit
sure and carrie that was somewhat
similar in that
she necessarily wasn't the bad guy in
the beginning but in the end she becomes
that as a result of what happened yeah
right so so
yeah it's driven by her story but
did carrie ever become the bad guy
though i don't think she was but
yeah i mean no carrie
that particular picture is really about
when you say that carrie is more about a
young woman becoming a girl becoming a
woman
and maturing into adulthood and
wondering the differences about her body
and trying to figure out
grounding herself and her reality
and trying to find her place amongst her
peers
and then really it went into the horror
genre because this is the worst it could
be
you know this is like like the way that
they treat it like that opening sequence
in the shower
is the worst thing that can happen to
you
in that smaller microscope you know of a
being a teenager that is the worst thing
that can happen to you being stuck in
that shower having your period and
everybody being like oh my gosh look at
her right you know so
it's an interesting movie i think it's
it's
there's so much there brian de palma was
a master it's interesting to bring up
carrie and scarface all in the same
yeah
and then he did uh blowout oh george
yeah absolutely and it's a filmmaker
sort of you know you know yeah maker in
the film and oh no i mean sound designer
i love the way like the sequences first
off the way that brian de palma always
used the split diopter
and he would have different parts of the
frame in focus and like do these split
screens like in his movie sisters
this amazing split screen sequence where
someone's being murdered and the other
person ends up seeing them and
i don't know he's such a master at the
split screen and really using the frame
in those kind of ways i'm also moving
the camera i suppose too because he
moved the camera a whole lot of crane
shots and
very complicated stuff
there's a great documentary on brian de
palma everybody should go see it oh
what's it called uh i think it's called
de palma i believe i i i i think it's on
netflix oh great you'll have to check it
out yeah i saw the the making of carrie
and um i'm trying to think of what there
was another one behind the scenes i saw
but yeah i'll have to check that one out
like you know like the exorcist the
exorcist is a great film because it's
about a little girl dealing with the
fact that her parents are divorced
and it's really about a little girl
coming to terms with the fact that she
doesn't have her father figure anymore
and i think that's what tugs at our
heart so deeply
and then she becomes possessed
and then we're not in a scary movie
we're in a
drama and i think that that's where the
departure is between certain scary
movies and other ones that are more a
little but they're all great though in
their own ways